[Music]
red dwarfs exist for so long that
eyeball earths could be home to
civilizations that make the human race
seem primitive and these alien species
would get to live in some of the most
romantic places in the universe with the
tidally locked planets providing
permanent glorious sunsets you're
looking at at a really low red Sun and
then looking back the other way so that
you can see stars that would be a really
beautiful place to live I bet that's a
prime real estate
the permanent sunsets wouldn't be the
only show in town red dwarf stars throw
off solar flares that could make eyeball
Earth's home to some of the greatest
light shows in the universe now red
dwarf stars are very stable they
actually last a very long time but we
have evidence that they have massive
solar flares which would actually strafe
the planets with extremely high-energy
radiation
these powerful solar flares can be
10,000 times stronger than anything our
Sun can produce but if these eyeball
earths are protected by strong magnetic
fields their alien residence could sit
back and enjoy a spectacular display of
brightly colored Aurora
red dwarfs may not be much like our Sun
but scientists believe the planets they
host are the best bet for finding
intelligent life of course none of the
planets that are earth-like are going to
look exactly like the earth just like
you know the neighbor's dog doesn't look
like your dog but it's still a dog and
if you're talking about life what you
care about our oceans atmospheres those
sorts of things and if it has all those
the fact that the maps are different
well who cares